we're asked to simplify em to the third
and then that squared all over em X to
the third all of that to the fourth
power and they want us to express our
answer in exponential form and then they
tell us that M does not equal zero and X
does not equal zero because if they did
then this denominator would be equal to
zero if either of them did and then it
would just be undefined so that's what
they have to put that little that little
caveat there that neither of them are
going to be equal to zero so let's try
to simplify this let me rewrite it so
the numerator is M to the third squared
and our denominator our denominator is
is let me do it in a different color is
M X to the third to the fourth power now
let's just work on each of these
independently what is M to the third and
then that to the second power well if
you raise something to an exponent and
then raise that whole thing to another
exponent this is going to be the same
thing so this numerator up here is going
to be M to the three times 2 power or M
to the sixth power
we're raising it to the third and then
squaring it and if you think about it
this expression right here let me just
do a little aside here M to the third
squared there's no magic behind why
we're multiplying that if you think
about M the third squared this is the
same thing as M to the third times M to
the third and if you saw something like
this you would add these two exponents
three plus three you have exactly two
threes here if you this was four you
would be multiplying it four times so
you'd have four threes so that's why
we're multiplying these two numbers
three times two so that gives us M to
the sixth and then the denominator here
we have M X the third to the fourth
power now in general when you have the
product of some numbers and you're
raising both we're raising the entire
product to some exponent you can raise
each of the terms to that exponent so
this denominator right here this is
going to be M to the fourth times X to
the third to the fourth I'm just raising
both of these terms m to the fourth X to
the third to the fourth power now what
does this simplify to
well our numerator
there is still m to the sixth I'll do
one step at a time our numerator is
still M to the sixth our denominator is
M to the fourth but we have this X to
the third and then that to the fourth
power so we can multiply these three
times four so this is X to the twelfth
power so times X to the 12 now we have
an M to the sixth and an in the
numerator and M to the fourth and the
denominator you could view this as the
same thing as M to the sixth times m to
the negative four either way but we know
or hopefully we know that this right
here this right here that piece right
there can be simplified as M to the
sixth minus four power so this is going
to be equal to so in the numerator we
could have m to the six minus four which
is M Squared that's the six minus four
right there that's what this simplifies
to and the denominator we still have an
X to the 12 we still have our X to the
12 in the denominator and we're done if
we don't want something in the
denominator we could rewrite this X to
the twelfth in the denominator as X to
the negative twelve in the numerator so
we could rewrite this whole expression
as being equal to M squared times X X to
the negative twelve either of these
would be an acceptable answer